ci sono persone che credono che fare
l'influenza non sia un lavoro vi
sbagliate fatte
vergognatevi par el influencer è un
lavoro a tutti gli effetti voi dovete
veramente essere inorriditi da voi
stessi quando pensato al contrario
perché oggigiorno è il lavoro della
tecnologia e lavoro del futuro lavoro
lavoro con la elle maiuscola è il più
grande influencer del 2019 signori
signori ce l'ho qui oggi e ve lo
presento il mio amico ha fatto un sacco
di like su instagram
lui è il futuro voi potete essere come
lui solo se vi impegniate un sacco però
sigla
non c'è nessuna sigla partiamo col video
amici miei non so se lo ricordate se non
ve lo ricordate
meglio c'è il mio amico che è entrato a
far parte anche di un videogame si
chiama toni ed è un nuovo cioè un video
vecchio che ho portato tempo fa però le
l'occasione dell'influenza il number one
nel 2019
ho voluto riportare itunes home per far
vedere che anche le uova possono essere
influenzare che possono tornare a casa
questo è il titolo del gioco
andiamo sul difficile per vedere che
anche io sono un ottimo influenze nonché
youtuber nonché astrofisico c'è l'uomo
che ha rotto il computer non ho capito
bene la trama di questo gioco ma non
credo sia importante è che vai io sono
semplicemente un nuovo che deve saltare
gli ostacoli ma non è così facile come
sembra perché devo anche
controbilanciare cioè tipo un getting
over it che non è che non c'è solo
creduto abbastanza questo gioco qua
perché devi anche controbilanciare come
ha fatto l'uovo perché vedi che su che
minchia tutto è difficile probabilmente
il video di cavo fatto sta roba era
pieno di parolacce i tempi sono che
adesso non lo è più perché siamo tutti
molto femminile andy b ovvero spikes sai
attento alle spine perché le spine sono
i peggiori nemici delle uova
un po come kim kardashian anche quindi
kim kardashian fa la parte delle spine
porco demonio o era la genere chi è che
aveva il record di mi piace nell'uovo
vabbè chi se ne frega non sono informato
su queste cose di storia ci sarà un
motivo porco schifo vai bravo o ragazzi
modalità hard chambray di let's get le
spine non serva prima la modalità facile
e questa sera mazza porco schifo che la
modalità normale semplicemente questa
senza le spine ma immagino almeno ci sto
prendendo la mano
ok no no porco il demonio morto perfetto
guardano come si destreggia guardali la
tua gallina sarebbe fiera di te bravo
zio bravo ma alla fine sempre l'altro
cade da un'altezza incredibile non si fa
niente ma delle spine lo rompono va i
toni mio bravo bravo così ti voglio
fratello bravo mi piace così mamma mia
mamma mia che giocatore è quanto alle
nato sta parte difficilissima perché il
caso sempre perfetto perfetto bravo
signori sono passati anni da quando ha
fatto sto video penso almeno almeno due
ma forse anche di un pelo di più sai
anche tre forze
il che mi rende orgoglioso del percorso
che ho fatto sul mio canale siano sempre
con questi video almeno sono diventato
un po più ordinato di capelli ho
cambiato il merchandise a proposito il
merchandise esce tra un po non adesso ma
tipo entro fine mese massimo chiesto
tizio allora cos'era è un tipo che mi ha
creato una piattaforma grazie alieno non
vedevo l'ora di rigiocare sta roba
comunque c'è sempre stato un po nei miei
sogni porco lo schifo soprattutto c'è
questo qua avrebbe potuto creare la
pagina di instagram invece di sviluppare
un gioco invece nello stile ho fatto un
gioco con un nuovo ed è questo lo
saresti ricco mannaia poi ci schiaccia
tema st barth e veramente difficile per
far cav h per favore salta l'ostacolo
quanto ci vuole a saper giocare a the
impossible game geometri dash spetta a
perfetto sono previsti vi è un the
impossible game misto a un getting over
i tuorli mente con un nuovo poi la cosa
che mi piace di più non è tanto luogo
insieme alla canzone port cava a caso
cascato sono ancora intatto l'importante
è non distruggersi non è tanto luogo in
sé quanto la canzone di sottofondo è
bellissima ma fa mica pirati 16 miss
semi cracco tutto non carlo cracco semi
fra il guscio tutto quanto alla fine amy
mitch e dovrà iniziare daccapo tutti i
livelli perché ho deciso di occuparmi un
pomeriggio così cosa mi dice il cervello
orca vacca guardano mi togliete
beethoven di sottofondo per cortesia che
non ci vedo il senso noi rate non so se
mi trovo in questo quadro la canzone
ragazzi sono sicuro che però non si sa a
provarsi almeno quello ecco i baffi sono
quelli di fabio mannaia quanto difficile
però ci credo ci credo odio la mia vita
dai mannaggia lo schifo bravo bravo
bravo bravo però così dai dove usciva
falsa parte difficilissimo ma ce la
faccio e difficilissimo ma ce la faccio
non lo sento effetto no orca vacca mamma
mia quanto quanto mi devi far esasperare
il suo gioco vai perfetto no a tua
sorella in padella e difficile mannaia
ho fatto i primi quattro livelli e basta
è difficilissimo ragazzi veramente sta
roba inguardabile e senza spina è una
cagata così impossibile
mamma mia che cosa ha fatto fatto grave
incredibile perfetto perfetto stato me
lo sento oh madonna
mamma mia che rischio no no ragazzi nota
è impossibile è impossibile è
impossibile acciaio vi giuro non so come
ho fatto ad arrivare fin laggiù non ce
la farò mai più sta roba sei ore è
infatti vi resto livello raga ve lo
giuro no no no no infatti vi giuro
infatti mirati e infattibile basta
meno tre ore che sono sullo stesso
livello casual casual fame lo casual
chissenefrega orribile sto gioco è
orribile senza le spine non le voglio
allora dai dai dai dai dai dai no ma tu
ti prego madonna bravissimo e sono un
grandissimo youtuber this is my land che
da ho sentito è fatti cavoli tuoi non ho
capito questo tizio non me lo ricordavo
ci sentite che vede la musica scusami
quest'anno nella terra delle uova
fratello non mi ha preso la mia prezzo
grazie restati fermato mentre venivo
preso cos'è dai toni no e vabbè
addirittura riquadro almeno slancio
iniziale aiuto ragazzi si sta sta
diventando veramente seria la faccenda
qua complimenti fatti livelli ci sono
per curiosità chiedo anzi sa mai
progaming ragazzi ci saranno degli speed
runner di perfetto complimenti diciamo
ci sono gli speed run e ho visto gioco
oggi non mi stupirei anzi ancora tu
basta che rottura ma cosa vuole quello
questa è la tua terra è veramente porca
vacca lo sapevo è veramente brutta come
terra tra l'altro non è per insultarti
lo dire che mi fissi tanto prima o poi
ti piglio c'è la musica di sottofondo
rende tutto il più epico possibile che
mi mancava veramente sta roba da finito
ancora basta cosa pensavo a te ne fossi
andato cori o muori varie annuncio le
gambe lo farei volentieri ma parca vacca
schifosa e ci sono dieci livelli così
ragazzi in altra questo qua il nuovo
super meat boy poi non lo sapete ma è
così porco demonio by michael schumacher
occhio occhio o ti occhio
perfetto no ti prego questo è veramente
geometri dash cosa è successo e se il
terzo livello ragazzi lasciano ancora
questo se ci sono così movimento
potrebbe essere molto difficile che poi
si muove tutto si muovono gli ostacoli
si muovono le piattaforme si muove anche
mia nonna mamma mia ragazzi su da ste
parti sono veramente difficili visto
veramente spaccando spero di riuscire a
finire sto set di livelli immagino di si
no
proprio adesso dovrà scendere con tutto
il tempo che aveva adesso porca vacca
porca la morta adesso adesso adesso mori
muori sempre se inutile
basta mamma mia come lo fregato qua
mamma mia che giocate alla pro
compliments guarda non saprei come
descrivere la tua performance sono
complimenti complimenti dopo un nuovo
elegante un nuovo in camicia bravissimo
che è ovvio non ti craccare più di così
perché sono un casino
no perché veramente mi sono craccato
solo una volta quindi non so sempre cosa
succede se mi sveglio tutto è lo zio nou
dove quella che vi che che reclama i
suoi territori dove finito è sparito ma
a questa un ascensore ok ma micra con
un'altra volta scommetti no non mi sono
fatto niente stavolta ok perfetto va
perfetto ci dice l'impiegato veramente
nel tempo per fare sto gioco complimenti
abbia finito fatti livelli ci sono il
latino fatti sette tutti madonna che
salto ai 13 perfetto negli ultimi sono
andato benissimo
ecco a posto ti prego ti prego ti prego
ti prego bravissimo brevissimo per vai
veloce grande tony che performance senti
cosa vuoi dalla mia vita todi di find me
e io sto continuando a prendersi portali
ma non ho ben capito a che servono
bene allora non importa più
puoi vedere la fine è sì vorrei la puoi
scegliere per te stesso vai via alla
scelgo destra sinistra sinistra
[Musica]